[Musique]
elle c'est le jour j pour l'allemagne
qui est à la croisée des chemins les
allemands sont attendus aux urnes
aujourd'hui pour décider du sort de leur
pays après 16 ans de règne pour angela
merkel a depuis 6 heures ce matin est
les bureaux de vote sont ouverts pour un
scrutin à l'issue incertaine
l allemagne compter jusqu alors 40 %
d'indécis parmi ses électeurs un avenir
flou pour le moment pour la première
puissance européenne un duel serré est
attendu entre le favori social démocrate
que son rival de droite elle les
allemands devront donc faire un choix
est la continuité de ce qu'a construit
angela merkel ou la rupture
et on retrouve tout de suite notre grand
reporter régis le sommier à berlin
bonjour régis alors les bureaux du verre
le blé bureaux de vote ont ouvert
outre-rhin
oui tout à fait les bureaux de vote ont
ouvert tôt ce matin vous l'avais dit à 6
heures et ici à berlin il n'y a pas la
foule encore vraiment les allemands ne
se sont pas encore précipités vers ses
bureaux de vote ici c'est plutôt le
marathon de berlin qui occupe toutes les
pensées les coureurs sont en train de se
rassembler aux dents centre ville et si
je trouve une allégorie assez
intéressante cette histoire de marathon
pourquoi parce que pour élire les
représentants au bundestag qui est juste
derrière moi eh bien ça va être donc
d'abord l'indécision comme vous l'avez
dit 40% date allemands ne savent pas
pour qui ils vont voter c'est du jamais
vu dans l'histoire du pays et surtout il
va y avoir un véritable marathon après
le vote une fois les relais délégués
désignés dans 299 circonscription eh
bien il ya aussi une répartition en
fonction des résultats des partis
politiques cette fois donc une forme de
proportionnelle et puis après il va
falloir désigner la coalition et cette
fameuse coalition il faut qu'elle fasse
plus de 50% alors tout un tas de
commandes de possibilités sont à l'étude
vont se présenter en fonction des scores
en fonction de qui a remporté quoi et in
fine et il risque de se passer quand
même un petit moment avant qu'on sache
le nom du prochain son chancelier de
celui qui va remplacer angela merkel des
allemands allaient si jusqu'au dernier
moment alors
des allemands totalement indécis on le
rappelle en 2005 lors quand viennent
lorsque angela merkel est arrivée au
pouvoir la cds ou donc le parti chrétien
démocrate et le spd les
sociaux-démocrates faisait plus de 70%
il y avait moins évidemment
d'incertitude aujourd'hui la cd ou est
autour de 23% le spd autour de 25% et
puis ensuite il y à d'autres partis les
verts autour de 10% die linke autour de
6%
l'afd donc parti d'extrême droite autour
de 10% et et comment les libéraux aussi
qui sont autour de 10% donc un électorat
totalement morcelé un paysage politique
totalement morcelé sur lequel il va
falloir composer avec lequel il va
falloir composer pour que les allemands
puissent se trouver un nouveau
chancelier
merci régis le sommier reporter pour
arte france on vous retrouvera tout au
long de cette journée pour parler de ces
élections